he's he's a comedic equivalent of the
world war ii jews selling the other ones
out danziatic
i saw them come down to put the figure
in z
here is my question today am i the only
one who see before we get to the seth
rogen clips am i the only one who sees
that not only is this we've talked about
the first generation fighting for less
rights and less freedom
but this is the first generation of
comedians actively endorsing leaders who
create
speech laws does anyone else see this as
uncharted territory it is
i am so unbelievably concerned i don't
even necessarily know how to put it
towards
let's just let's take a look more
recently on the ellen show how seth
rogen
just fawns over noted chief justin
trudeau
canada owns a house in uh in hancock
park
it's lovely i'd never been invited there
before and then they invited me
and and justin trudeau was there he just
showed up and was like i'm gonna try to
talk to everybody
and just walked around wow and he was
super handsome
he seemed genuinely happy he's quite an
amazing guy well you seem to
to be very impressed by him so much so
that you cut your wife out of the
picture because i saw that
that's the picture yeah
isn't he amazing that prime minister
justin trudeau
amazing enough to actively support
anti-free speech laws under the guise of
hate speech laws like bill c-16 which
was passed of course you know this
because jordan peterson
criticized it for its compulsion it's
compelling speech
and uh the faculty at wilford lauria uni
told lindsay shepard she was on the show
we had her on with jordan peterson
remember they met
that she may have violated it just by
playing a jordan peterson clip
this is the kind of policy that this
amazing trudeau supports trudeau's
administration is now actually looking
at bringing back an even broader
anti-free speech law
that he previously uh was he didn't it
was previously repealed
it would encompass online speech as well
sounds like the first one was just a
gate it's almost like it was just a
gateway
by the way hit the bell notification if
you're subscribed on youtube because
that doesn't mean anything anymore if
you want to actually be notified of the
videos especially because they could be
removed imminently
uh other examples comedian mike ward
we've had him on the show he was put
before a canadian human rights tribunal
fined forty two thousand dollars for an
offensive joke her joke
liberals support this the party of
justin trudeau comic guy earl was also
fined fifteen thousand dollars for
joking about lesbians who were heckling
him in the audience it's insane
think about how crazy this is seth rogen
supports the guy who actively supports
and campaigns for this
he's he's a comedic equivalent of the
world war two jews selling the other
ones out there in the attic
i saw them come down to put the figure
in the porridge they're off duty you're
so fast
you're so fast with this snitching you
guys would be the last people on the
earth protecting free speech if anybody
else would it's comedians you have to
you well
you have to but people like seth rogen
and amy schumer and trevor noah they're
the leaders of
of comedy right now that's what's so
scary this is this is totally uncharted
territory can you imagine
what comedy will look like 15 years from
now you know what's funny
about feminism absolutely
nothing because rape culture
is real now in case there were any doubt
uh as to the incessant unwarranted
fanboy worship
he hugged me which is weird and uh
he looks very happy to be with you he
seemed genuinely happy
i felt his muscles like press into my
body
like displacement like the amount of
space his muscles took up my body kind
of just
deflated smeared out of the way to make
room for it like when a boat goes in the
water yeah
it was uh it was quite a feeling oh you
blew
it aw
crap he's like don't know if you're
gonna compliment me don't don't
don't sell again not with the physique
they've got nice teeth
i have to it's beyond the point of being
realistic praise that's how you know
someone's a fan but that's how you know
you've gone into the realm of hero
worship like if you were to say that
about arnold like i met arnold
schwarzenegger i don't agree with his
policies
certainly not anymore but the guy was
jacked okay the rock sure
but to compliment trudeau on his
muscular physique
he's a woman without breasts or i would
even venture to say a very small one
here look
[Applause]
to be fair he did win one of those
fights oh good because the other guy got
exhausted kicking his ass
that was the best of a good strategy
they did the homer simpson defense
the contrast is hero worship of
totalitarian anti-free speeches
uh with with the once darlings of
liberal
i don't even want to say the left but
like lenny bruce lenny bruce liberals
love lenny bruce who stood trials for
offensive speech
comedians like bill hicks or the johnny
carsons of the world who saw themselves
as liberal but
i don't know i can't imagine that they
would align themselves with people like
this today
can you no i can't imagine it's just
he's selling out other comedians he's
closing the door behind him
like there's like those people in the
internment camps yeah the jews are
upstairs
so long as himmler has some awesome weed
[Laughter]
and this i don't know about you this
trend really bothers me more than any
other because we kind of we expect the
media
to be sort of left as complicit we've
we've sort of conceded academia and for
the most part hollywood but the realm
specifically of comedy it was always
supposed to be the last bastion of free
speech that final frontier where there
were no gatekeepers and you could
experiment
with your words that's really what it is
a comedian their only tool their
instrument
are their words we've had both left and
right leaning comedians before
never ever ever ever in the history of
comedy have we had a battalion of comics
looking to actively endorse and support
political candidates whose main cause
arguably their main cause
is the forcible removal of free speech
from the masses and even worse even
worse than all of this
it just makes comedy not fun comedy's
really starting to suck
it just sucks
you know i i always find it funny that
african-americans
you know are a little different largely
due to cultural and
social circumstances but are actually in
no way different or inferior and or
superior in any way to their caucasian
and or asian counterparts
and i would like to conclude this set
this evening by
holding hands and singing we are the
world
[Music]
hey did you like this video it
what you didn't oh you're a cat person
well that makes sense disregard him
and or her z everyone else hit the
subscribe button and leave your comment
below as to why you
like this video you know what crazy cat
you can get back you can you can comment
below too as to why you don't like it